bro you're here the alleyway lighter on
my seat the whole thing will be flashing
so you just see my eyes
just like this
someone stop him
everyone look back everyone's thinking
what and they just see my little eyes
with my little red flashing light for
the attendant
someone [ __ ] stop him
[Music]
all right my g's
while going guys you already know
what it is it's monday fun day um and
before we do anything else
literally pauses pause the video pause
the audio pause whatever you're doing
pull over if you're in the car
and head on over to patreon.com forward
slash [ __ ] thanks gigs okay we're doing
bits over there
50 of the content is on there yeah ma'am
we've just passed over the one year mark
so we've got a whole year's worth of
episodes to binge archive the catalogue
whatever you want to call it it's
magnanimous it's amazing it's funny it's
whatever you want it to be we've
officially got a year's worth of
episodes over on patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs it's going to cost
you three pound a month 10p a day run
the pvp you already know what it is okay
um is my laptop as well
gang um
so once you've finished doing that come
back over to us guys if you're listening
to this episode
uh do us a massive favor please
and give us a review right a nice little
review just a couple words it really
really helps us out helps us spread the
word um so we can start this cult moving
a little bit faster
um
as always chirp sitting in the comments
again we need breeding grounds white
robes and yeezys is the uniform
and we're thinking probably
utah 23.
[Music]
nice open space great ground yeah yeah
nice open space fenced up yeah man yeah
oh utah something like that around there
southern somerset yes
something like that yeah um 23 that's
what we want to do so if we're going to
make it in time for 2023 we're going to
have to chirps as many things we've got
to start now we've got to start now the
hard work starts now and we we reap the
dividends in 2023 guys okay so
like and subscribe if you're watching on
youtube
two fingers of death flick that
notification bell make sure you always
know when we're posting because we're
posting hot and fast and we can't keep
giving you a warning every time okay
can't you so with no further ado i'm
gonna head on over to the newly aged 31
firelord for eggs he's wiser now
and the facts are going to come with
more bigger [ __ ]
men said i'm wiser now why is that thing
that is hilarious um but yeah
your voice 31 now thank you for the
messages
and we move
so today's fun fact slash
um fan request if instagram doesn't want
to play up
is
i don't know if you've seen this
passenger allegedly tried to open the
plane door so the flight attendant hit
him with the coffee pot on the head
what
give me the details bro run me through
it
yeah a passenger was arrested after
reportedly attempting to break into a
plane cockpit and then try to open one
of the doors
witness witnesses said a flight
attendant used the coffee pot to stop
the traveler from continuing while
american airlines plane was diverted
an american airlines spokesperson told
the daily mail american airline flight
1775 with service from los angeles to
washington dc diverted to kansas city
due to an unruly passenger the flight
landed safely at mc at 2 28 pm local
time and the law enforcement was
requested to meet the flight on arrival
someone get that flight attendant a race
they didn't even actually explain as to
why he [ __ ] jumped in
can you even imagine seeing that though
imagine being on the plane and seeing
that some random donny trying to [ __ ]
get into the cockpit he's he's
yeah i'm going to open a main door
that's when i stress i don't give a [ __ ]
always doing in the comments section and
it's not i don't even know about that i
would think oh look at this prick as
soon as he turns to the main door
if i'm like way back and looking over
the seat i'll scream someone stop him
night flight as well everyone's sleeping
oh is it night flight everyone's
sleeping just got them little ding
lights on bro you're here alleyway
lights on nyc the whole thing will be
flashing
so you just see my eyes
just like this
someone stop him
everyone look back everyone's thinking
what and they just see my little eyes
with my little red flashing light for
the attendant
someone [ __ ] stop him
nah i couldn't see that
my heart would leave my chest brother i
would actually feel like some final
destination [ __ ]
there's actually um
you know i love my documentaries i
haven't seen it yet though but it's
actually a documentary on nettie um
about the
frequent crashes on the boeing 747
airlines or aeroplanes rather
than frequent family um this one i don't
know how how recent this is i'm assuming
it's more in the past but i think there
was like two or three in space like five
months or something like that and that's
too frequent so they've got they've got
an hour and 20 documentary on it which
i'm going to watch i've seen the trailer
and it looks very very very interesting
i don't know i can't watch them very
interesting but if you want me to fly
frequently now i can't
i can't watch stuff like that
with the storms in there man i see on
the news the other day one donny trying
to land
let's see two videos one plane trying to
land
the wind shook it he took back up
he was actually this close to the floor
fam the wind went wow man said [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that and it flew off
as a passenger in that i say what's
going on
oh
and then the second one i saw was when
donnie actually landed it
but bro said the ground say the ground's
here
he's flying in and the thing is swooping
to right left to right left to right and
when he landed you can hear like the
news cameras here you can hear everyone
clapping around and saying because he he
wasn't supposed to make it have you seen
have you seen some of the videos on that
they've posted on like lad bible and
whatever of all these humans human human
stumbling on the street for the cause of
eunice yes
funniest the funniest week as as as [ __ ]
as the storm has been that has been the
highlight of my week oh some of them
have been bella sent me a few let me see
if i can pull them up some
a couple people got draped
unwillingly literally like rolling down
the street unwilling it's so unfair it's
so unfair and it's so embarrassing
because i thought the wind i was
experiencing was bad because i tried to
i'm not going to
you nearly took flight
but i got i icked up yeah what did you
do the storm had me icking
just run into my car yeah to get in yeah
i opened the door thing flew open ah i
got in
i'm not gonna lie i pulled
i had to two-hand it
the wind said yeah the wind said what
you [ __ ] or
you [ __ ] or fam i took two handy and
pull it oh
dread embarrassing red that's very dread
this is
there's one where have you seen the zara
bag one oh fam well she got draped
around the pole and the bag was just
here she's there crap
oh my god arms all her gums gone bro
it's nice you'll see me have a tantrum
have you seen this one mama got flung
off the roof no what's that one
what's he doing up there anyway
oh my gosh man he's gone gone he's not
even in the shot
he's not even in the shot [ __ ] him
eunice took him he's not even in the
shrine eunice took him
i didn't know it was gonna be that bad
yo he's gone yo eunice [ __ ] took him
i love this one he snapped his neck i
love this one as well i just i've
already pointed yeah i saw that one why
is he doing that
ah don't mug me off yeah you're sure
[Applause]
i promise you now
if the wind's pushing me so hard that i
have the dad run you'll i'm never
hitting the floor
i promise you i don't care what i need
to stop what strength i need something
you'll never see me hit the floor
ah
eunice has been dropping bodies left
right and center it's too funny as
dangerous it is some of the videos i've
seen are too funny bro that wind is too
fierce bro it's dangerous it's dangerous
we've seen one like that we have a
humble little england
little island we've been comfortable
here we have we have we've been
comfortable global warning is warning us
fam fully warning us we've been too
comfortable yeah we're not that's
climate change we're not we're not ready
for that we're house cats it's not
climate change is actually is moving mad
mad bro i've never i've never
experienced such wind before like i was
in my yard obviously i've been off all
week last week i was just in my yard for
most of the days and i'm just hearing
because obviously you know my yard you
know that i've got the external door as
well leading to the mezzanine
so sometimes when the wind is doing bits
you can hear the wind peeping through
the gap
high pitch
i wouldn't want to be on the top floor
of your building because you you're
building a newbie
new bui
yeah that's dangerous looking down and
seeing the world in chaos yeah because
manchester had it bad as well yeah we
did yeah i couldn't be on the top
looking out the window and just seeing
my world in chaos
yeah that'll feel like day after
tomorrow oh bro i'm not surprised i saw
one
i saw one where
um
just regular road right one going this
way one going this way so there's a guy
with a dash cam video dash cam camera
sorry on his car so he's driving there's
a car in front of him and there's a bus
coming this way so they're driving this
way the bus coming this way
the bus is coming down there's a tree
just drops on the bus glass shattered
everywhere bro man had to swerve
quick swerve like it's gta sorry it was
west bro i promise you it was west brom
i'm finding the the closest shelter
oh i'm going home after i see that i'm
going home regardless of my current
destination coming home i'm going home
i'm going
here wherever bank is open wherever
anything i'm pulling up to the side
double yellows i'm walking in and no one
will let me leave no no one's going to
make me live i promise you that i'll sit
on the floor yeah eunice is doing bits
bro
bits i don't oh yeah man stay safe out
there guys yeah stay safe
what's the name of the next yeah that's
coming through storm
janice is that it i don't know i'm true
names
actually apparently apparently give me a
fun fact that i need apparently i saw on
twitter that
it's um you know the ones where you do
um
[Music]
what's the word i'm looking for a
petition type thing where you as many
names as you can for rubber apparently
that's how they named the thing
that's what i've been told the most
names that come through sight and stupid
like i don't know the dumbest [ __ ] i've
ever heard all right let me google it
now so we can do an actual different fun
fact um how are storm
wow they're listening to what's changed
to be fair they're
yeah i'll have to google that story how
do storms get their names
see i just hate just give me the actual
fact they love to dilly dally yeah they
do
they love to do it we'll come back to
that another time it's not going to come
up i'm not going to sit here and waste
you man's time
um
sharp left
have you seen
have you seen the genius documentary
kanye west genius oh right jean yas
genius nah
really good really really [ __ ] good
it's only episode one is that the next
episode is out on wednesday it's every i
think it's every week or every other
week wednesday really yes hour and a
half each app bro the first episode
inspiring really it's really [ __ ]
good james you should watch it obviously
i know kanye is going through always
going through now yeah but obviously i
feel like that's added publicity
so a lot more people watch it and it
works bro it's a really [ __ ] good
documentary you should definitely
definitely definitely watch it 100 bucks
i've scrolled over it like three times i
was thinking
nah bro it's very inspirational
we spoke about cardio like the last
couple weeks now
kanye
it just obviously not obviously but
this first episode is more of a
flashback into how he
came up into the game okay he was
he was obviously just pre all he did was
produce yeah yeah yeah yeah all he did
was produce for this guy that guy and
the other and he got his big break in
producing um for jay-z on the blueprint
free album
blah blah blah and that was his little
break but still then he was still trying
to make it into the
rap game because no one would sign him
because everyone knew everyone knew him
as a producer yeah yeah
so he was still hustling hustling
hustling people would backstab him he
made he's got friends here there and
everywhere but
nothing was patenting for him he was
living paycheck to paycheck to paycheck
to paycheck and sometimes when he
obviously kanye just he rants when he
talks now but when he speaks back then
18 20 years ago
bro he's speaking so much logic and so
much sense
it's unbelievable that it's the same
person oh he got lost in the logic
it's unbelievable that it's the same
person from now till then it makes sense
he's uh he was and still is a very very
wise guy he's a genius bro it's crazy to
say but he's an actual genius the way
this guy makes beats bro
he's an actual genius the documentary's
really good i'll watch it i'll watch the
documentary's really good i was i was in
golf for an hour and a half oh fair play
i watched golfed i'll watch it i'll
watch it oh let's see i've seen little
bits like him
beefing um
what the [ __ ] is that guy's name a guy
with the lips and the teeth the lips and
the teeth yeah there's one where's the
brother with the lips and the teeth um
[Music]
i don't want it unless it's brand new
you might see me and my brand
my brand new [ __ ] flipping that brand
new [ __ ] feeling like you get off my
brand new brand new dick rhyme fest
i had to get that i see a little trailer
of him b from rhinefest yeah i'm right
there's being like big how can you call
yourself a genius like how can you oh
bro your big self called yourself a
genius
it's mad and like it goes into
um different um what's the word i'm
looking for like different shots of him
and his mom stuff like that so his mom
is very wise as well very very wise the
conversations that him and his mum had
it just shows that what did you say had
i said
i couldn't let his lip i know exactly
what you said
after
the conversation that him and his mum
had yeah bro i don't know it's it was
very like heartwarming because obviously
we know the kanye of today we never
really knew the kanye of 20 years ago
what i did and personally anyway
obviously
and i don't know man it just brought out
a different line it made me understand
not necessarily why connie is the way he
is today but like we said in a previous
episode like kanye only really had his
mum
he was he didn't really have his best
friend i.e jay-z when he was trying to
go through the wedding stuff like he's
going through ups and downs and blah
blah and he's he's been [ __ ] hustling
his whole life to try and get to one
point
and then he finally made it and there's
so much other stuff has just happened
and happened and happened but the first
episode is really good i'm looking
forward to the second and third
second it's really it's really good i
tried to start watching um was it
inventing anna i've heard that's good
it's it's my girl roof though yeah
speaking you haven't watched those like
yeah i haven't seen whole thing the
whole thing yeah i finished it she does
speaking of ruth yeah
tell me she doesn't
um deserve an oscar for that last scene
i nearly broke the ting fan
when she bad
and it stood
when she said to my girl if you want to
stop me you're gonna have to [ __ ]
kill me girl
scream and she's in the car driving to
my man and she's absolutely going nuts i
didn't know that was the last episode
until it ended bro i was vex
the way she watched her in her face said
if you're gonna if you want to stop me
you're gonna have to [ __ ] kill me
kill me she screamed at me for like five
seconds straight i was thinking that's
real anger bro ruth did well in that
season oh she's got she's a great
character in general but that season she
broke out yeah yeah i already know i
already know
i'm ready sorry to call you off i
already know this i haven't gotta go one
of two ways the next the first episode
of the next half of next of this season
she's either gonna die straight away
or she's going to go hamper out the next
seven episodes yeah she's one of them
it's either episode one someone's gonna
put a bullet in her head or she's gonna
make it up to like the finale yeah just
have like a fist fight with the head of
the cartel
it's one or the other yeah yeah one or
the other she did she did well bro yeah
she did well that's that's that's a
thing man bro my my man i can't remember
his name the cartel brother uh my man's
brother when mama came to the yard and
he's like are you whatever and wyatt
um
oh my god he just came in yeah yeah bang
we warned you to stop you didn't stop
bang a massive sorry bang or sorry you
had to be here or some [ __ ] like that
and just left the baby and dipped
yeah man he's a problem yeah he is he's
a frog he's a problem he's like
he's literally just like power hungry he
reminds me of scar from lion king he
just wants it all he wants it all for
him he's a [ __ ] problem no that was
um
that was a great season even though it
was only half a season um seven episodes
i think it was gonna be another seven or
so on the next one but bro it was live
really good inventor anna
yeah talk to me about that i've seen the
trailer i watched the first episode it's
all right man i i don't think i've seen
it i've seen the trailer i don't
understand russian german thing bro i
don't know fam it's is no one knows what
it is no one knows where she's from
i wouldn't be surprised if later on in
the story i've only seen the first
episode i wouldn't be surprised if if we
find out it's fake yeah it sounds it's
obvious it sounds sketch okay um yeah i
don't know if i think it gives me mad
gossip girl vibes the weightless the way
it shot and the way it's like playing
out and it just gives me mad gossip girl
vibes hmm it's very
i'd rather watch the genius thing to be
fair
oh you should definitely watch that
actually yeah add that to your list for
sure fair play man um yeah speaking of
shows obviously um you hooked me up with
ranking of kings ah yes i'm on episode i
think i got halfway down halfway on the
way down here i think i'm like episode
eight or nine i can't remember maybe
nine or ten because it's not gonna be
further than me i haven't even finished
it
because there's only 18 episodes in
there yeah something like that yeah i
think i'm on nine or ten it's getting
juice bro
it's a good anime considering all man
does an ah it's a good anime
it's an anime but i told you it's
actually a good idea i told you for
weeks
i can't remember his name so just
just to give you guys a backstory um
jimmy spoke about ranking of kings um
maybe a couple months six weeks ago yeah
a couple of months ago um basically the
premise of the anime is um
they rank each king by
um how many people you've got in your
clique how
strong you are and
something else there's three things yeah
about the economy or something the
economy or something like that
um and this guy his name is boji so boji
is a deaf and dumb prince of a giant
king
i don't want to spoil has the why is he
why he's deaf and dumb and why he's
small but
he
he gets betrayed by his brother and his
stepmom i believe and he has to dip
the time when he dips with
um those two brothers to go on his
journey oh and the man
pushes him into the fire into the hell
pit
even bella was like yo
because i was watching yesterday and
bella came home from i think she went
out or two days ago i remember when it
was and i was just honest she was
watching it with me and she saw that
[ __ ] she was like yo
that is deep fam
because i didn't think they would do it
because obviously i saw him getting
close and i saw his face i was thinking
maybe he's just gonna grab him yeah
man pushed him a little little boy fan
pushed him and turned around and walked
back walked off and man was scary
where's boji he said boji has gone big
man
i said bojies guys what do you mean
he's gone he's done at it i had to drop
him
where's where are you up to what's the
last thing you saw if you recognize i'm
watching dead man he's gone through his
training yes and then he's gone through
your training yeah yeah and then man are
on their way back to
the kingdom no i think you're ahead of
me or or i'm unless i'm on the same
episode as you so you must have seen
when
you know the breda that is protecting
the queen
he'll heal whatever's quite hit the
javelin brother
no that's a different brother no the
governor's scar on his face yeah the
ballet guy yes the one guy yeah yeah
the lion things yes firm
yeah he went
he went wham he said yeah he went yeah
that's where i stopped i remember um
where i stopped was
they both of them bit him
because it did a flashback and set and
king king [ __ ] joffrey will call him
reminds me of joffrey anyway yeah he
looks like joffrey it's either me or the
mrs or me or boji whichever one it is
you gotta protect what's it gonna be and
that's where i stopped so i don't know i
don't know what's going to happen at the
end of the episode all right it's um
it's a really good watch yes considering
it's nice and now i understand as to why
you said that animation is the way it is
intentional yeah yeah it's the way it is
yeah yeah it suits that level of story i
like it yes the the king the giant he's
he's a big guy
he's he's a man
like that yeah he's he's a he's a he's a
rick ross a guy he's a guy yeah [ __ ] it
up he loves boji as well he does it
hurts him because the way he flashes
back
[Music]
it hurts him to see him
because when when the
giant queen gave birth she was like
considering we're both giants i'm
surprised he's so small man ran off
because he knew the deal
i said take it back take it he ran away
i said take it back
i don't want it anymore he loves but
even though early episodes he loves
tough times it's a good [ __ ] watch
ranking of kings is a good fight that's
a good watch it is a good watch it's a
different type of anime if you guys are
interested
18 episodes crunchyroll or nine anime
wherever you wanna watch your ship
ranking of kings yeah man live that's
our recommendation for the week um
i've got a young they don't really need
it but they
i think they deserve it
a young career appreciation gang we've
never done this i've done it in a minute
creative appreciation rdc world yeah yes
rdc world so who anyone who doesn't know
who rdc world rdc world are a group of
friends out texas they're youtubers
and um
they're way into anime way into gaming
and they're just dudes they all live in
the same house um
and they've been they've been making
content for years they make like that a
lot of their fame came from these little
locker room skits that they used to do
in the playoffs and they're like they're
into balls
yeah yeah like the last three years
they've done these like little lebron
skits in the playoffs and those have
gone mad
um and they've even got clips of like
lebron watching the video and stuff like
that they get gas
but anyway
they've got their own um
[Music]
like event okay called um i think it's
called dreamcon okay obviously they do
it once a year and it's like a comic con
thing oh and it's like anime game based
like just like a just yeah just a
convention thing okay and i i saw them
do uh like a highlight roll of their
2021 version the other day
it's
[ __ ] massive i'm surprised
like it's bro it's [ __ ]
huge
like proper like convention center huge
bro
thousands of people wow and this is
their own event that they run every year
and everyone's just there for anime and
gaming and good times and they have
little gaming competitions and they got
all this shut [ __ ] like cosplay
competitions yeah all this stuff and
it's like rawr
just a bunch of youtubers set this up
it's [ __ ]
massive
i would love to go one day
bro props so i had to give them like i
said they don't need they've got like
[ __ ] like four million they're clear
they're doing just they're doing all
right yeah they're clear but found when
i saw the size and the magnitude of this
thing i was like
[ __ ] that's how you know you can you
can do what you want you can do you can
really do what you want
literally you can really do what you
want guys literally imagine being
someone that like oh wouldn't it be cool
if we had our own like version of comic
con and then you did it and then it got
it gets to that [ __ ] level [ __ ] fear
i wish you could see it's [ __ ] huge
show me a bit oh yeah i'll show you all
the cool things
it was on instagram that i saw what i
would love to see is what their first
one looked like to the one last years
look like i would love to see the
comparison yeah yeah
that's dope man that's very dope
that's very [ __ ] dope man you can do
what you want in this world guys
don't let anyone tell you otherwise it's
[Applause]
don't like to say they like mud so much
because a lot of people that make fun of
people for liking those type of things
but here at dream car you ain't gonna
get mad
guys oh
[Applause]
bro it's sick man it's ridiculous sick
where was that
uh they i don't know where it was
but they i know they live in texas i
don't know if it was if they if they're
hosted in texas or whatever but bro
yo how sick would that be props man
big big big big pups big props big
[ __ ] props bro they deserve the most
but yeah man i think that's so [ __ ]
cool people can literally do what they
want um
i got a lot of uh
thank you i got a lot of congrats
messages when i told everyone that i
quit my job the other week that was cool
thanks guys
um and as i was just saying throughout a
little while ago i haven't ever once in
the last also been two three weeks now i
haven't once like had that like [ __ ]
what have i done yeah [ __ ] what i've
done yeah because obviously when i quit
my main job like nearly a year ago now
is it that long
may may 21. damn may 21 is when i did it
damn well played yeah like it was nice
in the back of my mind it was nice to
like get a part-time job
to like kind of just be like cool like
i've i i'm technically a podcaster now
but secretly i'm still i'm still making
money yeah that's not podcasting money
yeah and it's nice but
quitting this job
i thought would be like okay this is my
safety net gone now yeah yeah yeah
you're free for all yeah yeah you're
you're cutting your parachute off um
like here we go it's game time i thought
i would have that like that urge to be
like [ __ ] yeah like what have i done
like i need to start making content like
crazy but fam i've been chilling good
man that's what we love to hear that's
what we loved here chilling you deserve
so yeah
i tell him all the time guys i tell him
all the time he deserves all the bags
you don't understand what this guy does
for this pod what he does for you man he
deserves all the bags this is his dream
you know
yeah
yeah man yeah man you just have all the
bags thank you bro thank you um so
you've got uh
a segment for us yes so
a lovely fan sent me a dm saying
um
i should check this link and it's a tick
tock of
the caption is please comment the
meanest things a guy has said to you
it's for research purposes and i'm being
serious so here we go the meanest thing
i guys said to you so um thank you for
sending that into me and yeah
are you i usually only date models so
i'm actually showing you i care by
making an exception for you
that is dread
[Laughter]
that is dread yes it is fam that's
strange i don't know where some men get
away with their luck i don't know i
don't know how to get away with it they
they can't live in major cities because
major city yeah
yeah this must be like durham and
dempsites
because there's no way
you're telling that to a london chick or
a
baby
exactly this is a durham hoe for sure
for sure it has to be
it can't be a major city ho yeah she's a
durian [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh god
yeah
oh it's okay to starve a little bit
that's it oh he's calling her fat yeah
i'm okay to starve a little okay to
starve
[Laughter]
oh bro this is
you've told me how upset you are like 50
times and i've cared maybe twice
[Laughter]
vicious vile creatures didn't we
my ex said to me
you cry about your dead dad to get my
attention about two months after he died
that's peak brother
that's peak brother that is peak to be
fair
i don't know maybe some people do though
oh my god oh god and you've got one in
it when i'm with you
i feel like i could be getting other
things done instead my god
yo man what's pushing these man to say
that i'm
i promise i couldn't get my words out i
promise you these aren't major ceos
because mandam can't talk to major city
holes like this yeah they can't it
wouldn't run they they won't run how
dare you
it wouldn't run
it can't bravo these are bournemouth
yats
has to be yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
in um in brackets
grabs my stomach while cuddling
quotations looks like someone needs to
hit the gym
grabs it fam just like just plays with
it looks like someone needs to hit the
gym while he's doing looks like someone
needs to hit the gym wow boy
rob yes fight talk fam
him okay him staring at me me the girl
what are you looking at him
i'm trying to decide if you're pretty
you're not
nah
men are wicked oh yeah men are wicked
they are they are they are they are
gone i only like you when i'm drunk and
you know that oh my god that and you
know that oh my gosh
i don't know that
oh
don't play with me because you know that
don't bail me at nine o'clock in the
morning you're sober babes what is it um
what's that weekend song
which one
um
i only love you when is half past five
[Music]
i stopped being attached i stopped being
attracted to you months ago when you
gained weight but it shows how much i
love you since i'm still with you [ __ ]
bro
what are these man trying to accomplish
with these bars fam
i'm only with you until i find someone
else to be my wife
to be fair let me stop you there for a
sec
a lot of these sound like [ __ ] that
women would say just because it's
wednesday
do you know what i mean
just because it's wednesday
with like obviously men can be [ __ ]
brutal
but fam i've
how can i say this
i would say on the whole in my
experience yeah women are far more
spiteful oh that is a fact that is a
fact women are far that is a factor
we don't even need to discuss they enjoy
an argument saying [ __ ] that that will
hurt you it will hurt and two it's not
relevant to the current argument women
love to bring things from the past oh
they they live for it ah they store it
oh they they store it they need to
because they're thinking about it i'm
just going to whip it out whenever i
want
because he's addicted that's hilarious
that is i can't remember i saw a comedy
sketch about that
very recently as well but i don't know i
don't remember if it was an old comment
sketch but i know i just watched it
recently was it was it most thing
because i watched moans on netflix the
other day and he does a lot of this chat
maybe because maybe i've not seen moe's
but maybe i saw a snippet of that maybe
just sight
slight left turn
most things banging you know oh i don't
doubt that bro i didn't i'm a fan of him
i was 50 50 in his last one i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it but i didn't think it was
like a revelation this one's [ __ ]
good gang this one's [ __ ] good like
he's come into his own in this way i
love that yeah you can tell he's like
how do i explain it you can tell he's
picked a lane that he finds funny and
the kind of chat that he finds funny and
he's just double down i love i love his
the conversations he has with himself
yeah yeah
the way he talks like that i love that
yeah yeah the relationship bits that he
does on there
hilarious bro
hilarious brother yeah he
had to give him his flowers on that one
yeah gilligan smashed it gang we loved
it smashed it well played more well
played more i'm gonna watch it soon
wait until i'm with my next girlfriend
she'll get everything you asked for
that's something i'd like to say to
someone one day
wait until i get because that's a
precipice argument that's like you
didn't just say that off
the cuff yeah yeah we've been arguing
for 45.
we've been arguing for 45
and you've asked me
bed washing up picking up clothes this
that that that fam and you've pushed me
here yes
you've pushed me here and i've said to
you wait till i get my next thing she'll
get all of this she'll get everything
she'll get all these things are coming
out your [ __ ] mom she'll get all of
that she won't even have to ask
because my next [ __ ] will deserve it
i guess i'll find a 10 instead of a 6.
[Laughter]
to me that's vile
that's why
wow
you're worth absolutely nothing and you
deserve everything i did to you
wow
that's absolutely dreadful that's pimp
chat
that's what that is
you just have everything i dip to you
you can't say that in a domestic setting
fam that's pimp chat
the funny thing is you treat me better
than anyone i've
the funny thing is you treat me better
than anyone ever has and i treat you
worse than i've ever treated anyone
that's
some men are atrocious that can't be
real
you're not going to put makeup on
question mark
you know what that's a valid question
sometimes
i'm sorry to be that guy bro i really am
i really am i'm not i'm here for the
conversation hit me but some chicks
don't look right
not right right harsh
some females without makeup it's like
how do i explain like mando without a
trim
yeah
yeah
yeah like sometimes i think that would
i've i would never say that to a girl
but
some girls take the
makeup to such an extreme anyway yeah
that way that without it yeah it
literally looks like i'm my hair my
beard's just growing as it wants yeah
yeah and then it's like literally same
as a girl saying to me like big man so
you just not getting trims this year
are you just not getting nice for me
you're just not going to get a trim is
that what you're saying
to me that's exactly what that sounds
like and i would feel that's justified
if i go say that to me so what we're
just not doing trims then
this is you now yeah because i just want
to know
sometimes with certain girls the way
they use that makeup that's a justified
question fair play bro i hear that in
that aspect when you're comparing it to
the trims thing of course
ah
come on go on go on i can see why you
get beat
that's not funny
why do you think i did my icelander
that's not funny at all
i got made fun of for dating
yo
i saw
i saw a meme the other day that was like
i can't remember the face they used but
it was like
when you
when you finally send your ting to the
mandam in the group chat and they say as
long as you're happy bro
i will scream confirming
your man or your girl to the mandem or
gather in the group chat is
oh fan that's why my our whole
friendship bro any time i've ever said
anything and you're always first to be
like roll run me a picture man i bought
this chat
i would have been like no man
just take my word for it
i don't want to run your [ __ ] picture
i'll never forget bro obviously never
going to say your name i'll never ever
ever ever ever forget bro we were
talking about this chick i was like
obviously dude run me the picture man
said
i'm not trying to lose a friend today
sat in along those lines brother i died
i died immediately i remember i remember
i remember where i was when i sent you
that message
i was in the car park of the gym in my
car i was in grill on the market oh i
was at work brother yeah i remember you
saying i'm not trying to lose a friend
nah it's not one of them oh you're
hilarious brother
i get that you're insecure
but you're the only girl i'm talking to
right after i saw a bunch of girls on
snapchat dead he told me i got lost in
his snapchat list and followed it up
with
out of sight out of mind
dread
dread
follow up
thank goodness you're wearing makeup now
wow from
okay
wow
you could be prettier but it's okay i
like you enough
mad
i'm not posting a pic of you because i'm
embarrassed that we're dating
yo
that was instagram beef i know that
argument
man said
i think i'll find the right one
eventually but you'll do for now
yeah some of these men are heartless
brothers i can't let's wrap it up i
can't stomach these anymore fam that's
just too much i'm deadass out of your
league so i don't know why you're acting
like this
[Laughter]
wow
the thought of being with you doesn't
make me happy brother
yo
now we have to stop because
but that could be for days i i'm tired
of defending these men i'm not but these
are some of these
some of these are precipice arguments
they're
because people women like to say about
our context sometimes with it with them
you might either what did you push me to
yeah for me to say that what made what
made me say this to you yeah yeah yeah
because there's been times that i
remember there was one time i was on the
phone to an ex
at your house in manchester okay well
this one the the one previous one
previous
and
i was she was beefing me
beefing me and i was trying to stomach
it stomach it stomach it and be polite
polite polite polite until she pushed me
over the edge and i just had to just
longer out in one sentence bro or one or
two sentences and just destroy our
entire world
and then just like afterwards like
again you get that clarity and you're
just like oh why did and you want to be
like why did you make me say that this
is your fault why did you push me to
this because i tried to get off the
phone 10 minutes yeah yeah and you
weren't having it and now you're balling
making like i'm the bad guy yeah you
pushed me to this
you pushed me to this
i don't want to be that guy
i don't want to do that yeah but you
left me no other option oh my days
that's hilarious yeah but it's horrible
man i hate [ __ ] like that it's vile bro
uh men are wicked so were women but uh
the thing is like like you said before
women are more spiteful but men can be
cut the [ __ ] throat oh we can be cut it
when we need to cry now that that's what
we could cry prepare to cry because i
can make you cry right [ __ ]
i'm just a nice guy yeah
i can make you cry right [ __ ] now
darling i'm just a nice guy
yeah you know what i mean i'm not a
killer but don't push me don't [ __ ]
push me revenge is like the sweetest joy
next to get [ __ ] that's all i need to
say what time next time i get had up
like that fam
babes i'm not killer but don't push me
if i'm revenge is like the sweetest joy
next again [ __ ]
that's hilarious
that's hilarious
oh my dad jesus christ that's hilarious
but yeah that was [ __ ] funny i love
that yeah i need to see the flip of that
because i'm telling you now
the opposite of that is way worse oh i
know that for a fact wait i know that
was a fact i know that was way
worse and every woman sitting there
listening to this listening to all these
piece of [ __ ] men know that the opposite
of that is way [ __ ] worse mandem
tweet us right now
uh worst things a woman has said to you
yeah hashtag sng fam let us know while
gwan gang tell us the story gang let's
go from right now worst things a woman i
said to you because i know it's
it ah bro i know it's off the wall bro
it's it's it's not funny oh jeez but
anyway um let's go into a quick am i the
[ __ ] okay am i the [ __ ] apparently
this one's an emergency one i don't know
when she sent it oh
time ago yeah whatever it is is done
it's kind of emergency now
um i have an emergency in my of the
[ __ ]
so a close friend i've made through uni
and i have recently started sleep
together
as friends with benefits it's quite
risky as we're very good friends we take
the same course and live in the same
halls
but
but the communication between us has
always been really good
and we believe that although there were
risks we think we can do it
so far it's been [ __ ] great and i
even went back on the pill
rather than both of us having to use
condoms matting what do you mean both of
us have those condoms is she using that
that's remember that yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know what it's
called i know exactly what you mean both
of us all right um he told me a few
weeks ago he was going on a date with
another girl from our course which at
the time i was fine with she won't fight
with she yeah of course um i don't know
the details but i know he's not looking
for anything serious or relationshipy
with her
as we're so close i think it's a really
good idea for us both to also see other
people to stop us falling into a
relationship with me which neither of us
want
they went on the date last night which
apparently went well but nothing
happened except that they agreed to see
each other again
and he was talking to me about it and it
just made me feel really ill and
uncomfortable pause i think that's
[ __ ] weird i would never
well i'll put a pin in it we'll come
back to it we'll come back to it so i
want i do want to
i think it finally dawned on me that he
could end up sleeping with us both
although her and i are not really
friends per se we have a lot of mutual
friends and will often be invited to the
same parties
if he slept with her after a party or
something then it would be it would be
different but seeking out a person who
is in our social circle makes me feel
very uncomfortable
i don't want to put him in a position of
having to choose me or her but at the
same time i don't feel comfortable with
continuing to sleep with him if he
starts sleeping with her ideally i'd
rather
him sleep with someone stroke people
outside of our mutual social circle
as i said the communication is really
good between us but i don't know what to
do am i the [ __ ] for wanting this
slash seemingly changing my mind where i
thought i was okay it turns out i'm not
please help
well we'll come back to certain specific
points but off the cuff i don't
necessarily think you're an [ __ ] for
changing your mind people aren't
entitled to change their mind but i
think
you're an [ __ ] for not you're an ass
i think you're very naive to think that
you'll be a you thought you'd be okay
and now you're not yeah that's very
naive
regardless of who he's [ __ ] and she
already said that she said initially
they're not friends or they're not even
in the same social circles but they're
not friends with each other no she said
that
her and the other girl you mean yes
they're not friends but they're
basically acquaintances from the same
similar circle yeah but she didn't say
some social circle she said we often get
invited to the same parties that's
different to being in the same social
exactly now she's saying social security
so she's making it seem as if they're
closer than they really are
to make you're digging for you're taking
added
so for the fact that for her to then
contradict herself and say i'd rather
her sleep with someone else that i don't
really know babes it's the same thing
it's the same [ __ ] thing because the
point i was going to make earlier was
when
um
she said they went on the date and she
said that he said it was going good and
that he might see each other again that
for me is a no-no yeah i would never
tell a chick i'm [ __ ] how a date was
with someone else read the room man it's
just read the [ __ ] room it doesn't
matter what they say like oh i don't
care
[Music]
just keep that [ __ ] to yourself so now
so obviously i can understand why she's
feeling how she's feeling because
because she knows what his dick's like
she knows that he's slanging out
somewhere else yeah
that's tough so i don't i don't
necessarily think you're an artist
before changing your mind i just think
you're very naive to think that you
wouldn't be hurt in the first place yeah
you should have made different
arrangements in terms of this
communication thing and be like right
let's just be open and honest about the
fact that we are dating but there's just
certain specifics like you don't need to
know you don't need to know who it is
you don't need to [ __ ]
find out or went on a date today we
didn't [ __ ] but we agreed we're going to
see her we don't need to talk about that
they don't matter ignorance in that
aspect is soul bliss because if you're
trying to have a healthy quote-unquote
unrelationship type thing you have to
you have to go with it open-minded you
can't care you can't have attachments
all of these stuff they don't matter
they're irrelevant yeah like it's
irrelevant how do i explain it like
obviously me and your boys yeah
if if you said to me
oh i'm chilling with my boys tomorrow or
whatever sick i'm gas for you now if you
now tell me that me and my bridges have
just signed up to a ping pong league i
didn't need to know that
why you need to tell me that you would
be livid
you would be like
bro
a betrayal
the [ __ ] betrayal
yeah me and my boys meet up every
thursday for some ping pong now you're a
[ __ ]
you're absolutely a prick that's our
thing
[Laughter]
oh yeah this is sad [ __ ] you don't need
to share yeah there is man you can keep
your communication lines open and on
this but why would why because that's
the thing he said oh nothing happened
but we agreed to see each other again
what if something did happen yeah but
then he would have come and be like yeah
it was actually decent she came back to
mind we had a few drinks and we [ __ ]
how would you feel i think we're gonna
go yeah yeah it's silly man it's so so
silly so for future reference and for
ladies listening out there if you're in
a not even a relationship if you're in a
little fling thing with a guy you're
having fun both of you have discussed
you don't want a relationship with each
other you just want to have fun
don't tell each other what you meant are
doing it's stupid yeah man just saying
i'm seeing other people even if it's
okay to even be like oh i can't i'm
seeing someone tonight or whatever if
they said oh if you get that little
tonight question mark he's like oh can't
i just like if i'm busy doesn't suffice
you say oh i've got other plans tonight
or something like that
don't you oh yeah i've actually got a
date on thursday with this girl because
this
all that's pointless it ruins the whole
thing you've got with this with girl a
it's pointless guys yeah friends with
benefits or not like if you're having a
physical relationship with someone just
keep it pg bro just
keep it ambiguous about it
no if you don't she doesn't need to know
she doesn't need to know keep it i need
to know that's that's that's what i like
that's what it is
i need to know bro yeah um but yeah hope
that helps yeah mom um obviously this
one's [ __ ] but hopefully your next
friend
helps but um yeah man as always guys
patreon.com catch us on thursday for the
good vibes and the jokey jokes um thank
you to
everyone who is jumping on the
uh patreon zoom call this evening
looking forward to seeing you there
eight o'clock tonight make sure you're
there and um guys
have a good one love love gang gang
[Music]
you